ok welcome everybody to the workshop on
curriculum standards and international
benchmarking it is my pleasure to
introduce our two panelists for this
session first we'll hear from Kelly
burling who's the director in the
National services division at Pearson
which is a leading education company
with comprehensive offerings to help
inform targeted instruction intervention
and assessment so that success is within
every reach of a student I feel like I
just read your a commercial there thank
you i will i will end there because that
their bios are in the program so i want
to don't want to spend all our time
reading their bios Kelly will be
followed by David albury who's an
acknowledged global expert in the
formation and implementation of
strategies for fostering radical
innovation and transformation and
education and public services and he has
a quite extensive record in public
service and serving for the national
government again which is in more detail
in your packets here so we're going to
start with Kelly first and then followed
by David if you have clarifying
questions while they're presenting feel
free to just raise your hand and ask
them a clarifying question about one of
the slides will then open it up for a
broader substantive questions once they
both finish their presentations okay so
with that Kelly it's gonna duck under
here and I am going to remove the
microphone from up here and walk around
because I'm tall enough in my high heels
I don't need this additional height I
was hoping that I would get to be the
only tired person here but I'm probably
one of the few people who has the least
excuse i'm from this very time zone and
everybody was at the hotel with the 5am
fire alarm going off last night so I
have no excuse whatsoever obviously not
everybody was the local people hadn't
heard that it was quite quite a fun
evening um you may have noticed that I
don't have the word curriculum anywhere
up there in my presentation title I am
actually not going to be talking about
international benchmarking and
curriculum standards at least not
directly
I'm going to be talking about the
assessment portion of international
benchmarking in the last presentation
that was in here we heard the word
benchmark quite often used somewhat as a
noun we're using benchmarking more as a
verb here so I thought it would remove
us to start with some level setting what
is the definition of benchmarking that
we might be working within the context
of this presentation benchmarking is
generally more of a business term so I
got a lot of recognition and research
early on and it was about defining
processes about defining processes that
happen in an institution in an
organization and looking to see how one
compares to another organization it can
be for identifying where one stands
relative to other people it can be as a
formative process for improvement and
change when we're talking about it as a
noun it is often a single measure that
is used to establish one's position
relative to another here are some
popular definitions up here I'm UNESCO
and definition of benchmarking I liked a
standardized method so we do like to
standardize things so that we have some
confidence in the comparisons that we're
making and if the standardized method
for collecting and reporting the
critical data in a way that enables the
relevant comparison so it's obviously
about comparison making comparisons
figuring out where we stand relative to
whatever we're interested in wherever
we're interested in going comparisons of
performances identifying areas of
strength I press in the middle am I
going to get the new there we go the
pointer view to establishing good
practice diagnosing problems in
performance and identifying areas of
strength when we talk about the
international assessments that we use
for benchmarking don't know how much of
that process we think we get at we tend
to end up looking just at test scores
right how do we compare in math how do
we compare in science how do we compare
and reading is it really about this
method of teaching an institution how to
improve
the title the presentation was
assessments for the future the
assessments currently don't do much of
this for us in terms of identifying the
processes for improvement identifying
the practices that we want to move
towards we at Pearson think that the the
field needs to move in the direction of
creating assessments that do actually
push us forward in identifying those
processes that make us better and
actually causing that change the
assessments can do that they don't have
to just measure it were in a changing
world obviously this the information the
technology that students are faced with
on a daily basis is changing what's
being expected of them in the working
world is changing we need to change what
we're measuring and how we're measuring
it at the same time we cannot just rely
on the same standardized measurements
that we've been went been using what I'm
planning to cover the role of
assessments in benchmarking in the
international benchmarking what
assessments are out there I'm sure most
people are probably familiar with the
major assessments there have been some
changes in additions in recent years and
want to make sure that people are aware
of them and then talk about where we
think assessments need to go the
assessment Tim's pearls Pisa p a kilo
and then the one that doesn't really
roll off the tongue ATC 21 the longer
one how many people in the room are
familiar with all of these assessments
obviously the other panelists here okay
who is familiar with four of them okay
three at least two yeah most people are
at least two we're going to talk briefly
about what all of them are and Pearson's
involved in all of these so we're going
to talk a little bit about our
involvement in them and then how we're
trying to push them forward as well why
do we do these international assessments
like we said with the definitions of
benchmarking it is locating us ourselves
all of our countries relative to current
states of practice right we want to know
where
stand relative to everybody it's because
of the global competition out there it
is important for us to know how we stand
globally much more so than it ever has
been before we are educating workers who
are going to other countries to work we
are educating workers who are competing
with people from other countries for the
jobs it is an international world we
need to start looking at where we stand
with students in elementary school in
order to make sure that we are going to
be globally competitive we also need to
identify the models to follow I who are
the leaders why are they the leaders and
do we think that the assessments are
measuring important things do we want to
go to follow the models that the the
leaders the people who are doing the
best on these assessments are what
they're doing in their countries and
then progress monitoring just as the
last presentation talked about
monitoring the states of students in the
schools in New York City monitoring
their progress towards proficiency we
don't have definitions a proficient to
hear but we do know where we want to go
who were shooting to to emulate who's
how we want to move up in the standings
and we can monitor our progress Tim's
first was the third international math
and science study now it's trends of
international math and science um Tim's
is in the fifth cycle just about to be
in its fifth cycle of assessments they
say dedicated to improving teaching and
learning and mathematics and science it
is really a content based primarily a
content based assessment relatively
traditional content based assessment
there's a huge background survey where
they collect a lot of information on
classroom practice but the assessment
itself and the the items that students
are exposed to a relatively traditional
and it's their goal is like all the
other international assessments to
inform policy over time help countries
make decisions about education policy
reform etc pearls probably one of the
other ones that people who are just
familiar with a couple of the
assessments is familiar with it's an
international reading literacy study
very much the compliment to tims is man
Zion study every five years beginning in
2001 again provides good background
survey data but more this about the home
environment and learning to read then in
the classroom environment and
instruction and reading Pisa the long
description here pizza is that program
from the OECD measuring 15 year olds and
it is much more about what they term
fluency and for people who are reading
specialist or maybe really involved in
the reading debate in the u.s. their
definition of fluency and literacy means
something different they really need the
application of these skills in reading
math and science in complex problem
solving in real-world context it is a
different type of assessment more
challenging higher-order thinking skills
assessment than what Tim's tries to do
in each assessment cycle they do their
measurement every three years they
measure reading math and science every
year but in each assessment cycle there
is one subject area that's given
priority a Hilo assessments of higher
education learning outcomes this is
another OECD program a newer assessment
that's program that's getting underway
and it is to look at what students can
know and do upon graduation from higher
education no longer do we just want to
compete compare how we are doing from
k12 and k10 in other areas we want to
know whether or not our education of
higher our institutions of higher
education are providing comparable
worthwhile education we want to
hopefully use it to improve teaching and
provide policymakers information for
essentially accountability purposes and
i don't mean accountability ala NCLB but
accountability as and we are putting a
ton of money into our higher education
institutions internationally they are
supported by
governments with a lot of federal money
and is this a worthwhile endeavor are we
getting out of these dollars what we
think we should and it will also help
employers know what the the graduates of
the various institutions are being armed
with p ack program for the international
assessment of adult competencies this is
a little bit different this is about
both what adults need to be personally
successful but also what they need to be
successful members of a society it's
going to be it is going to be designed
to determine whether or not whether the
instruction in social competencies are
relevant to economic outcomes in various
countries similarly it's a it's very
different undertaking than most of the
international assessments have been kind
of kind of exciting will be really
looking forward to seeing results of
this would come out this is new program
what are the impetus for all of these
these colors are terrible sorry for all
of these international assessments and
why do we think they need to changing it
better this is from levy Murnane Harvard
researchers this is about the types of
and I'm not even sure I can read this
from here excuse me that's terrible
color I apologize the inputs for what is
required of people in the workforce the
top line up here says routine manual
non-routine manual routine cognitive
non-routine analytic and non-routine
interactive and this bottom definition
here follows this line this top green
line these since nineteen sixty compared
to 2002 these are the job
that are being required the inputs that
are being required in the in the
workforce sixty almost sixty five
percent of the jobs are now requiring
non-routine interactive tasks whereas in
nineteen sixty routine manual was about
would get you just about as far in being
employed there are no longer jobs
available for people who cannot do
analytical non-routine problem-solving
it's important for us to oh goodness
move us keep moving forward as well as
in my slides assessments role in
changing these outcomes okay but not
only not only do they measure inform
policy and form practice and decision
making and institutions what is test it
gets taught right I mean we all that's
an adage but it is true people
concentrate on what gets taught that
matters for the international
assessments as well as what get happens
for both local domestic national
accountability movements the national
assessment systems in high in the high
achieving countries on these current
international assessments are linked
differently to curriculum than they are
in this in the countries that are low
achieving they're much more integrated
in the instructional process and they
are designed to both assess and improve
teaching for learning teaching learning
for students and teachers the assessment
process can be instructional for the
teachers and the students it is not just
taking a sample of what they know not
just what is taught but how it is taught
new directions for assessment the one
that doesn't roll off the tongue
assessing and teaching 21st century
skills is really trying to move this
assessment debate this assessment
movement forward as well Pearson who's
been involved and has a significant role
internationally and within the
implementation of all those
international assessments in the US
we're trying to advocate for a change in
the way some of these assessments are
being done to turn them into learning
events and to get more information out
of them quickly this is the 80
see two ns which is the partnership of
Intel Microsoft and Cisco I will not
read this because I'm pretty much at a
time right now but this is essentially
their call to action the reason why they
want to do these assessments there's
great information at the atc 21 s org
website about all of the work that
they're doing major rationale for their
project society economy work changing
everyday life is changing there has been
little change in education this is not
just the US the Chancellor talked
earlier about going to sleep 120 years
ago waking up in classrooms looking the
same that is not just a problem in the
US and because of that we need to change
assessment current assessments reflect
these old practices maybe if we change
assessments we can change the way the
pedagogy works as well really quickly
he's in the future we are trying to push
for measuring new assessment constructs
we need to get these 21st century skills
these soft skills we want to improve the
use of technology not just for the
collection of data and the reporting of
data but for the measurement of things
differently cost control efficiency a
lot less exciting improving the
assessment and I mean the analysis and
use I would put up there of assessment
outcomes we get all this data new york
city is talking about the interface that
they use to present data to teachers and
parents to make it useful we need to
make this wealth of data much more
useful that we have from international
assessments the new constructs that
we're talking about on 21st century
skills however you want to define that
there million half definitions out there
situational judgement decision-making
can we measure that yes develop learning
progressions it's one of the things that
we have a strong research agenda in at
Pearson right now we need to define what
these skills are and how they are taught
if we say that they are necessary for
being successful in the world we better
say we know how to get people there so
they can be successful you have to
define the progress how do you get to
the point of being a successful critical
thinker what do you tell a teacher if
their kids aren't measuring up oh
teach the same thing over again go ask
them do the same task now you have to
give them tools to get there that's what
learning progressions are all about some
of the definitions of 21st century
skills what we want to measure
creativity adaptable adaptability safe
legal and responsible use of information
technology I mean it is all over the
place this is so much different than
your basic algebra and literature
assessments that we are used to one of
the ways that we are doing things like
this we can do a team communication and
this has team communication assessment
looking at problem solving collaboration
and situational awareness team decision
making people are put into collaborative
environments they talk they type can be
literally talking or typing in a chat
room environment we can take that
information and measure them on the fly
about their collaboration skills their
decision-making skills and
decision-making skills under pressure
and at this point I'm going to say that
I'm going to pause okay we'll keep going
learning progressions I was talking
about briefly I just I cannot emphasize
enough how important i think this is we
we can all talk about the fact that we
are living in a different society and
that people need to do different things
but if we do not get everybody to the
point where they can do those things we
are going to continue to have this
divide we cannot say that this knowledge
is just going to get transferred kids
are going to become critical thinkers if
we expose them to enough writing
assessments or make them do enough
research reports it's not enough we have
to figure out how it gets done and then
teach teachers how to teach it to the
students or at least facilitate it in
the students and this research will also
let us be able to score the work that
we're assessing the learning progression
essentially creates your rubrics for you
right so what is the basic looking
expression of a skill what's the next
step after that what's the next step
after that not only is that telling you
how to teach it and the different steps
to getting to greater mastery but it
lets you know how to score it
thanks i'm going to skip a lot of this i
think that we need to define effective
teaching and we need to do that in the
u.s. probably more than in some other
places but improving the analysis of
assessment outcomes means using our
assessment results to figure out what
works in teaching right and i'm not
saying that we need to then you know hit
people who aren't doing a good job over
the head with a stick i'm saying let's
figure out what is effective who is
effective use our assessment results to
figure that out and then figure out why
right if we can teach critical thinking
to students we can definitely figure out
what good teaching is and start to
provide professional development to
teachers it's all it's all teachable
we've got to use our this wealth of data
for supporting continuous improvement in
enclosing here we got a little ad from
Pearson at the beginning i'm going to
close with a little ad from pearson here
too but truly and honestly it's a
fabulous company to work for in part
because we are so comprehensive if we
work together within our company and
within with our partners we span k two
in-service teachers right i mean that's
the full in higher education that's the
full spectrum of education if anybody
can make a change Pearson has the
ability to do it if we can figure out
what the right answers are so the the
research the use of the assessment
information we ourselves are responsible
for for making sense of it and for
implementing some of the change so we
have this global reach because of it the
pressures on our shoulders as well as
everybody else is to use it and make a
difference do something good with it
David thank you okay hello and what I
want to talk about it and it's all sort
of beyond benchmark
living and it's going to build on what
Kelly said and also hope you cook up
some of the issues that joel klein
raised in his address in lunchtime so
skip over some of the slides because
we've covered them in some detail and
then focus a bit on one particular
collaboration between countries but it's
it's sort of interesting to me here we
are sitting in a an urban education
summit and over the last 10 years
there's been a huge growth in round
tables in debates in for our in summits
around the world of ministers or
education officials of teachers of
practitioners coming together in spaces
like this for a day or two days and
learning a lot from each other and it's
been fantastically valuable and we've
heard from Kelly that there's been a
huge increase in the amount of data
available on international benchmarking
the ability to compare education systems
one with another and these to the
international benchmarks and the round
tables feed off each other people like
to come and here they talk about each
other and how they're going and so on
but gradually what we're getting is not
something that's just about
international benchmarking or
international dialogues or international
summits but looking more and more at
what real-time collaboration between
different countries different
educational jurisdictions might be but
it's really over the last 10 years as I
say that we have this growth in
internationalization and we're all now
hopefully by the end of today all
familiar with a list of reasons why
there have been these why this interest
in internationalisation why this desire
to compare and the reason for that is as
many people have said already that there
are settle profound global changes that
are affecting education systems in all
countries developing and developed
countries in continents across the world
we've heard Kelly showed a slide earlier
about
the nature of skills for living and
working in the 21st century I've listed
some there occur time and again team
working problem-solving creativity
lifelong learning gathering analyzing
synthesizing information perspectives we
know that technologies now are almost
ubiquitous several of the speakers this
morning referred to the fact that people
have lots of students not all lots of
students have more technology and more
learning devices more abilities to gain
information and gain learning outside of
school than they have inside of school
chris spence this morning talked about
students in Toronto but I've heard it
from students in New York students in
London students in Beijing that they
feel as though they come to school and
they have to power down they have to
forget the ways in which they normally
learn in order to come into school we
have an explosive growth in accessible
information i still have my chemistry
textbook from when I was at school a
single book that call comprehensive
chemistry it claims have everything in I
needed now I have as many pages of
internet sites as I did a single
textbook and I have the ability as an
individual to access that their
information the world is more connected
and simultaneously more diverse both in
our cities and in our countries and
around the world and there are global
challenges around climate change and
around poverty eradication where they be
in developed countries and pockets in
cities or whole countries in some parts
sub-saharan Africa and these these
profound global changes as we've heard
many times require profound changes in
education the sorts of education that we
had for the 20th century will not work
in the 21st century will not equip every
student with what they need the skills
the knowledge the values and the beliefs
and the attitudes to live and thrive in
the 21st century so we started mapping
actually this is a diagram from
publication that
developed some two years ago called
equipping every learner for the 21st
century which just tries to map the
development the evolution of education
from traditional education systems
through a period of reform where the
focus was on curriculum on teachers and
accountability and on leadership to what
we call education 30 21st century
learning which is much more holistic
which talks about developments 21st
century skills knowledge values and
attitudes that still is about leadership
people and cultures notice a quick shift
here not just about teachers but how we
engage adults in different roles in the
learning process it's of course also
about high quality infrastructure and
technology and it requires a different
sort of reform agenda so how do we
create this sort of collaboration this
is just one example but I think it's
probably the most recent example of
collaboration between countries who come
together around a common purpose the
purpose of transforming their education
systems so that all schools all students
all learners are equipped the 21st
century a set of partners who've helped
in the design and development of this
program but I want to draw attention to
what we call the jurisdiction partners
the countries that were involved in this
Australia chaoyang which is a district
of Beijing but given its China that's a
district of almost 5 million people
England Finland Ontario New York New
Zealand South Korea and Victoria from
Australia and recently we had me vent in
Beijing hosted by our colleagues in
Beijing and what was interesting to me
finland's and South Korea Finland has
been top of the PISA tables for the last
I think for Pisa for the last three
rounds Kelly probably two or three
rounds South Korea over the last 10
years has moved from something like 23rd
or 24th to second for
the second in the league table were they
coming to celebrate their success no
they were coming to this event to say
we're top of a league table that is the
wrong league table we're playing the
game that's the wrong game in order to
have an education system that's
purposeful and fit for the 21st century
we need to transform ourselves as much
as the other jurisdictions and countries
that are involved it's a recognition not
that it's something it's not just about
catching up it's not just about
comparing ourselves to who the leaders
are now it's about being able to move
beyond that to a place where we can
create the learning environments and I
deliberately don't use the word schools
the learning environments the
organizations and the communities in
which children and adults can continue
to learn throughout their lives and
equipment sales with the knowledge and
skills that they need so guilt is a sort
of it's a it's a very strange thing it's
a social movement this is the global
education leaders program it's a
leadership program but it's a
transformation program it has five
objectives it's its primary objective is
how can we use the combined efforts of
different countries on this
fantastically difficult journey how can
we get the different countries different
cities not just talking to each other in
single events but really helping each
other devise that the strategies and the
plans and the methods and the mechanisms
from taking it from where we are now to
where we need to be it's of course
developing the leadership capacity of
people within those systems to achieve
that transformation it's growing a
community of those leaders that can
advocate with PS mm with others for the
necessary changes in assessment regimes
and accountability regimes and so forth
that's necessary and it has to continue
to advocate has to continue to say these
changes that are taking place in society
require profound changes in our
education system so it's creating a
global movement towards 21st cen
free learning and it's not just people
we do come together sometimes in real
time and we do sometimes quite a lot
come together virtually as indeed
learners do we have to model how
learners will be in the 21st century we
have to learn not just in rooms like
this but being able to network virtually
between those events but it's also about
providing consultancy support to each of
those jurisdictions those countries
those cities and providing personal
coaching to each person involved in the
program and finally making sure that
that networking that online support
works very effectively people learning
from each other because peer learning
peer assessment is as powerful in these
new systems students assessing each
other's work is as powerful learners
assessing each other's progress is as
powerful as any of the top-down systems
that we've talked about of course the
curriculum is a vital part of this and
many people have talked about elements
for 21st century curriculum over the
last few hours it's not about discarding
the basic skills often people say is it
just about team working and
problem-solving collaboration what about
literacy what about numeracy on these
still important and of course they are
but it has to build this broader range
it's about disciplinary knowledge as
well as multi disciplinary knowledge
it's as much in a globalized world as
about ethics history and citizenship as
it is about disciplinary subjects in
fact it's about a whole range of things
I'm not going to go through this i think
the slides are available on your flash
drive the point i want to make is a
point that just to emphasize what Kelly
said earlier on which is a focus on the
curriculum reform which is important and
a focus on assessment which is important
is not enough the pedagogy the methods
of instruction the methods of learning
you are as important arguably more
important and more powerful than what
specifically is taught it is about
inculcating a desire and ability to
learn that is the predominant skill of
the 21st century so two very quick case
studies glimpses of what countries are
thinking about before I finish first
chaoyang in Beijing as I say when you
took out district for City this is as I
said almost 5 million people the work
they're doing with the support of the
global education leaders program goes
under the banner of internationalization
of education how can they develop what
they're calling students international
capacity this capacity for students to
live in a more internationalized world
and they have three goals in that they
have a goal about creating a society
creating learners creating students
creating adults who are innovative who
know how to cooperate and collaborate
and to understand respect and mobilize
different cultural understandings their
strategies for doing this they've taken
three elements of this curriculum reform
leadership development because
developing the leaders of these systems
and of the schools and of learning
environments is critical and about
assessment techniques some countries
have become very good through rote
learning and through conventional
instruction at teaching people bodies of
knowledge that is not the same as the
sorts of instructional methods and
assessment methods that are necessary to
create and sustain a love of learning
Victorian Australia does this work just
about using the enabling and technology
of what they're calling the ultra net
creating ubiquitous technology are
focusing on creating a modern and
professional workforce note again not
teachers or not just teachers
one of the features of 21st century
learning will be much more
differentiated roles tutors mentors
coaches experts experts facilitators
differentiated rose probably not the
single role of a teacher about the
enablers for learning about changing
role of government we've heard many
people I think all the examples every
speaker this morning talked about
releasing the energy within the
education system and within communities
to develop innovations not seeing them
as top down and equally as joke i
mentioned at lunch time talking about
the ways in which you can get a broader
base of providers not all as it were
public schools in the conventional form
but how do we get to diverse to a
provision and critically is as chris
spence mention this morning how do you
actively engage parents and communities
in this process how do you mobilize the
demand side so two very quick glimpses
not introduce five minutes i just want
us go through as it were where i think
this takes us my argument is there are a
set of universal challenges challenges
that affect all countries and all
education systems in a sense that goal
is a common goal creating education
systems creating learning environments
that equip enable every learner to have
the skills the knowledge that values in
the police the 21st century but there
are many many different pathways to get
there they very locally because we agree
on a common goal the culture and
politics of different countries and
jurisdictions mean there are different
routes to getting there but we can learn
from each other all of this of course
underpinned as i've already said by you
bit Chris technologies I want to end by
just making a couple of minutes on this
funny phrase about disciplines
innovation I make what may be a slightly
provocative remark on this there are
hundreds
thousands probably millions of
educational innovations around the world
but we tend in education systems to do
this in a rather informal and ad hoc way
other sectors and increasingly parts of
the education sector have learned that
there are methods approaches techniques
tools that we can use to discipline the
innovation process not to eliminate the
creativity in such a way that we can
create more powerful and more integrated
innovation and we see one of the
commonalities as we look across the
different countries and different cities
involved in this is a gradual emergence
whether it be in New York of what's
called the innovation zone the Izone
whether it be in countries talking about
innovation labs whether it be particular
groupings of schools is the application
of those two parts of the system to
really drive those forward so
disciplined innovation is a key part of
these innovation instructions but
critical and my very last point is we've
often concentrated too much on as it
were just creating the innovations and
not enough on making them system-wide
innovations and part of the secret to
that I believe lies in not more
publications or more conferences or more
exhibitions but finding ways of
mobilizing parents students and
communities to demand those innovations
those new methods and approaches as part
of the education system so I hope that's
been helpful and maybe provocative thank
you
so now we have a bit of time for
questions and discussion so if you have
a question for other by two panelists
please come to the mic one of the
microphones here and please identify
yourself yeah my name is Martha hill I
have been talking to you David I'm sorry
hey you that in in one of the
powerpoints was changing role for
government would you mind explaining as
deeply this part thank you the I think a
lot of what took place in the last
decade of the 20th century and the first
decade of 21st century was very top-down
changes changes driven from the center
of government and you can affect those
you can affect some sort of changes in a
top-down way you can drill people you
can instruct people to do particular
things but you can't dictate to people
or instruct people or command people to
be innovative or to be creative to
develop new models of education so the
role of departments of Education the
role of governments i think is
increasingly moving towards creating the
conditions in which disciplines
innovation can be built from the bottom
up that new models of education and
learning can be built from the bottom up
rather than attempting in government to
enforce a particular model top down and
all the lessons from I think from
singapore from other countries is that
if you can do that in a disciplined
you do unleash the creativity so the job
of government is creating the conditions
creating the environment in which these
transformations and innovations can take
place and that involves issues around
incentives or OMG accountability and so
forth but the actual job of developing
these new methods of learning and new
environments for learning I'd argue can
be facilitated enabled by government but
can't be directed and instructed by
government
David one of your slides mentioned
cohorts and this is my own ignorance
about the the program how do countries
districts etcetera get involved in what
is the cohort model in your program um
as I said this is this program is not
you know you come on it for one year and
then you transform your system and
that's it oh that it was so easy this
program is a growing social movement so
it started in its first year which was
now some 18 months ago we've just four
systems new york city ontario victoria
and england and then we've been joined
this year expanded a number of countries
with as i say we shall yang beijing with
South Korea with Finland with Australia
international level in with museums so
the idea is each year we bring more
countries on Oh can any country join yes
there are no there are no there are no
rules of entry except except there's no
tests no assessment but there are two
cry I guess there are two criteria one
is they are they have all been countries
and systems and cities that are
dedicated to the transformation of their
education systems not just the
improvement of their education systems
in current ways they're not just there
for there's a lot of work to be done
don't get me wrong people should
continue to improve their educational
systems but also build a capacity of the
new but unless you believe in having to
build that capacity for the new this
program isn't really them and secondly
obviously there's some although in cisco
and Gates Foundation have very
generously funded the first two years of
the program we look to each
participating country to be and other
funding partners to be contributing part
of the costs of the program in relation
to their country
that yes it is thank you yeah I relate
to ask question about measurement over
21st century skills and competencies
traditional pen and paper tests I mean
Bailey's test your knowledge
understanding it's very relatively easy
to administer it basically just mcq
questions in the running through machine
it and performance analysis for you but
measuring of important skills like
collaboration ability to working with
other people managing diversity
synthesizing information it's a whole
new set of complex skills that require
the thinking process and documenting
that that part of the thinking process
and my hunch is III don't know I haven't
seen any model that works that is
relatively low cost now how can we
reconcile I haven't seen any model at
this point in time that works how can we
replace the traditional form of
assessment with the new competencies
measurement and probably any any besides
the ATC 21s which Singapore so soon mm
bro huh we're trying to figure out how
to do that any particular models both
Pearson Cisco canticle okay can I can I
add to that so our visitor our friend
from Singapore's question because this
gets at a conversation between the two
of you I think David made a point of
talking about those 21st century skills
so disciplinary knowledge specialized
skills ethics history citizenship and
that raises all sorts of questions about
benchmarking and assessment so help us
figure out how what models are out there
and how to do it well it seems to be a
big challenge moving from basic skills
to more complex skills I think there are
a couple of different promising
approaches and they are radically
different from one another the Microsoft
Cisco Intel project the ATC 21 s project
is looking to define they want to very
clearly define these 21st century skills
and define them in ways that are
measurable
and they are looking at technology-based
assessments and the research that they
are pursuing right now that I think is
most impressive gets to some of what I
was talking about with defining
progressions as well as looking at
really interactive innovative online
item types and I would point you to the
work of Mark Wilson who does something
which he calls construct maps which are
very akin to learning progressions he's
also the principal investigator for lack
of a better term of the bear be EA RS
Essman system and he and his colleagues
other colleagues with the bear
assessment system Kathleen Scalise at
University of Oregon are building really
innovative and when I say innovative my
standard is pretty high online
interactive items we're not just talking
about drag and drop we're not just
talking about stimulating environments
for for doing a lab experiment that kind
of look like a lab table and I'm
knocking everybody right now who's doing
this including Pearson I mean the work
that is really innovative has not been
brought to scale yet but their work
isn't really really interesting and
hopefully can't be brought to scale the
other approach completely the other end
of the spectrum we have to abandon some
of the psychometrics that would go along
with some of those innovative items we
have to get away from our idea of a 3pl
model in a scale score one of the
projects that we're working on right now
is looking at standardizing the type of
information that teachers can take out
of their day to day classroom
interactions so helping them better
understand how to elicit a complex
performance in a classroom interaction
and how to get data out of that that can
be used to compare teachers across
classroom so they could talk to other
teachers and say my kids did this when I
asked them
s and the their scores were this and
having that feed into essentially a
student information system a massive
student information system if you
collected that type of information even
weekly about kids as they were
progressing in your tasks to develop
critical thinking you would have a very
good understanding of their trajectory
and their mastery of these complex
skills and we can't do these complex
tasks other than and really embedded
they take time they take guidance they
take kids having enough time to go and
work on their own independently or in a
group it is not something that you're
going to do by setting them down in
front of a computer for an hour and
giving them some interactive items so
really it's about creating situations
within the classroom in which data can
be extracted in a way that's usable by
teachers and comparable across
classrooms and it means there's a little
less standardization than most of us in
standardized testing are used to I mean
I I do genuinely agree with all that so
there's two just two or three builds on
it I think the colleagues from New York
in the previous workshop said well what
really matters are the outcomes and the
outcomes of course aren't red scores the
outcomes are sort of how people succeed
in higher education for talking about
school level skills or in careers and so
forth and therefore New York is to be
applauded for trying to stretch out the
sort of length of time that people are
looking at those outcomes and when we
look at those outcomes employers and
colleges really want two things it seems
to me one they want some form of
benchmarking or standardization but
increasingly they want a demonstration
of what that individual learner has done
and is able to do and therefore what we
see in this area is the development of
more and more eportfolios which are
collections of students work that
straight the mast real particular skills
and competences so if one takes oneself
away from measuring the outcomes at just
the end of school moment and says how do
these students achieving in college or
in careers we can start to create a more
powerful way of powering school than the
k-12 learning experience and the other
thing which I didn't mention right
slides which audience is very on their
reaction to list is I am struck as I go
around schools in the US in Europe some
schools in Africa and Australia about
really about the power of peer
assessment people believe that students
if they assess each other will engage it
will be very soft with each other or
whatever I think all the experiences
that if you engage students in peer
assessment actually they're pretty tough
with each other they're pretty good at
assessing whether teams are working well
together and it's after all more about
how we assess each other as adults then
making people do petit the tests on it
so alongside the standardized the sort
of new things that Pisa and Cisco until
Microsoft are doing and are about to
trial in real places in real time I
think there is these things that
outcomes in e-portfolios and I think
there's an air around performance-based
assessment and peer assessment in that
process but i am absolutely with you
that the biggest single challenge we
have because if we're sitting there as
leaders of systems i'm not going to
throw away an old system where I've got
lots of benchmarks about its performance
for some person standing up and saying I
think you ought to wander off into its
nice fluffy space which has no measures
and no benchmarks about it
going to be serious and get governments
and education leaders committed we have
to take very seriously the challenge
that you posters I just want to add to
that the the work that we're doing in
the classroom environment where we're
trying to help teachers extract data
from classroom experiences it really is
based on any portfolio model where we
are actually trying to capture artifacts
of student learning over time both
evidence of them doing interactions in
class as well as a project that they
would create what we're finding is not
everywhere has that technology
capability so until that point comes
we're trying to provide the tools to
help them understand what you would be
looking for in your classroom artifacts
or classroom interactions because you
can't store it but you can store the
score much more easily so if you can
collect that data while they're doing it
that's our proxy for the time being yeah
but the idea of a portfolio that follows
a kid from K through to the their
working life it's yeah brilliant what we
hope for other questions maybe just to
add on some from some thoughts today
what another component I thought we need
to address is both parent and employee
employer education of assessment
literacy if alternative assessments can
come in then they're going to see a
Ygritte in a mess or a great or B grade
or whatever in English it's going to be
a different form probably I don't know
even mention of portfolio you have to
interpret what the child has done in
school so it's another area of thumb is
not just the the the stream of the
instruments in schools but also whole
society a whole mindset change that we
really need to address as well the nice
thing is that just was reading a
pamphlet about a school in so happens it
was in England which involves the
parents as well as the students in the
assessment of the performance is that
the documentation the project whatever
maybe that they that the students are
generating so I recognize again that
people are very familiar now with the
sort of stands a progress report and so
forth and we need to have something that
as engaging and helpful in them as
understanding but I think it will be
different this interaction and
collaboration is a really important part
I think the defining and I'm going to
keep harping on it but the defining of
the learning progressions if they're
done in language that make sense to
parents I mean if it's much more
interpretable to me as a parent to say
my child is here in understanding how to
read than to know that he's got a great
equivalency score or he that the metric
level of such and such or has a scale
score it was there was a lot of work
done I don't know maybe within the last
10 years about scale anchoring for all
these tests where we have these scale
scores let's give an item or two to
people to represent what work is being
done at different levels of the scale
why why should we need that if we can
embed the assessment in real
performances let's describe what those
performances are because we all know
what the performances mean I know what
it looks like when my five-year-old is
or isn't reading or is there isn't doing
separating beans into appropriate
category something like that much more
than I know what a 157 means one last
question
don't all jump up at once okay thank you
although I'm had yes so please let's
really thank both David and Kelly for an
engaging and subset of presentation